buenos días aquí soy steve de bueno de
link no y siempre hay gente que me piden
de hacer un vídeo en español porque hace
mucho tiempo que yo no yo no lo he hecho
y bueno voy a explicar un poco en mi
proyecto lo que estoy haciendo ahora es
el desafío no debería buscar desvíos
desafíos ya yo no me acuerdo pero este
es típico de lo que ocurre en el
aprendizaje de idiomas porque hace mucho
tiempo que yo no hablo español ni menos
y no escucho español entonces voy a
confundan voy a hacer errores pero esto
no es muy importante porque mi español
bueno lo hablo menos bien que el francés
o japonés o mandarín o pero lo hablo aún
un nivel
en un nivel determinado
lo que hace que a un niño si yo no hable
español voy a perder bueno palabras voy
a dar palabras voy a decir errores voy a
confundir la construcción también voy a
buscar construcciones de idiomas eslavos
porque mi cerebro está acostumbrado a
pensar de forma como por ejemplo en ruso
en polaco y hablando español
al principio voy a buscar esas
soluciones no para exprimir me pero
después de un rato pues voy a hablar
español como antes y quizás aún mejor
porque siempre tengo la impresión que
cuando dejo un idioma
estudio otros idiomas volviendo al
primer idioma después de un poco de
tiempo porque al principio es más
difícil pero después de un rato lo hablo
más bien que nunca bueno el desafío que
estoy haciendo ahora es de concentrarme
en el estudio del coreano
qué es un idioma que tratando de
aprender 23 veces y cada vez bueno logro
a bueno a alcanzar a un cierto nivel
nivel pero no un nivel suficiente para
verdaderamente entender por ejemplo
puestas sobre políticas sobre económica
sobre filosofía sobre literatura cosas
que para mí son muy interesantes
entonces está bien durante tres meses
voy a concentrarme y voy a escuchar y
leer y atan links en link y revisar mis
links y eventualmente voy a hablar pero
para mí hablar no es tan importante
porque es puede parecer muy sorprendente
pero si yo escucho mucho y leo mucho
mi capacidad de hablar va a progresar y
la prueba por los que veían mi vídeo con
hannah en georgia no tenía un gran bueno
salto
en adelante no sobre solamente a través
de la escucha y la lectura
claro que para hablar bien hay que
hablar mucho
yo siempre siempre lo digo pero para
y alcanzar un nivel potencial en el
idioma
precisa es preciso necesitas palabras y
es las palabras se adquieren a través de
la lectura y la escucha y bueno entonces
yo estoy convencido que después de tres
meses de estudiar concentrado del
coreano
yo voy yo no puedo decir porque este es
una otra
otro tema que
nosotros podemos medir en link mi nivel
de actividad y si voy a leer mucho es
que escuchar mucho voy a obtener
progreso pero yo no puedo decir que voy
a hacerme bueno voy a hablar al nivel de
fluidez porque éste tiene muchas muchas
cosas pero para si ustedes si vosotros
queréis concentrar los en un idioma en
el estudio de un cierto idiomas durante
tres meses va a progresar esto es cierto
ok y yo
puesto que decide de concentrarme
concentrarme en el coreano para mí era
muy importante y buscar contenidos
interesantes y he encontrado un sitio de
podcasting en coreano con
transcripciones con los textos y es muy
interesante y sobre la política en la
república
coria coreana y yo soy muy contento y
solamente falta el tiempo para dedicarme
totalmente a este y claro que el español
lo hablo un poco menos bien pero ahora
pero no este no es impacto importante si
yo te tendré la posibilidad o la
necesidad y necesidad de hablar más
bueno
hablaré mejor es bueno ok este es una
breve discusión en español es sobre lo
que estoy haciendo ahora con mi desafío
en coreano adiós
y hasta luego